hi my name is that and I will be your
instructor for this reaction
fundamentals course in this series we
will be creating a simple gocbar single
page application which will allow us to
search and investigate through popular
TV series we will cover such topics as
gsx components in containers state props
conditional rendering react router and
much much more what you'll need is some
knowledge of JavaScript HTML and CSS
the course will contain some es6 and es7
syntax but don't worry I'll explain
everything along the way I will not be
assuming that you know anything about
react so which and every line of code
will be explained with great detail in
this course you will not only learn how
to write react code but you'll also find
out how to maintain and organize your
code base to keep your code as clean and
readable as possible so pick up your IDE
and try to code this out from scratch
along with me in this Reax fundamentals
course
we will be using an official yak
boilerplate created by Facebook's team
you also need to install no GS on your
local machine I already have it so I'll
skip the installation part but you can
download it on no GS dot org let's go
back to the github page and first of all
what you need to do is you need to npm
install create react app with the global
flag and this will take a few seconds
now that we have it installed you can go
back to your create react app github
page scroll down a little bit and here
you can see the quick overview I don't
need to use this npx so I'll just copy
create react app paste it in and the
first argument is the folder name I can
actually show you if I remove the folder
name if I press ENTER it will say that I
need to specify the project directory
for example create react app my rack tab
and I'll do just that
and I'll name my app TV series app so
this will probably take a while I'm in
order to you now that our app has
successfully been created
I'll change directories queue the TV
series app and I'll type in MPM start
press ENTER and this should spin up the
development server if you're speeding it
up for the first time it'll probably
take a while and congratulations on
setting up your react environment
what you're seeing right now is the
boilerplate that creat react app
provides us let's open up the code
editor and see what's inside I will be
using atom but any other IDE will work
just fine you go for your app lives
inside the SRC folder so we will be
spending the majority of our time here
the main file is syntax yes so let's
open that up and here we can find find
five imports let's talk about each and
every one of them the first one is the
react library itself without it you
wouldn't be able to create react
elements the second import is react Dom
which initially was part of react
library but was split into its own
eventually it works as glue between
react elements and the Dom and usually
you will just use it to render your app
as we're doing here the third import is
an index dot CSS file so nothing too
interesting going on here just a simple
CSS file fourth import is the app
component which we're currently
rendering you can open that up don't
worry if you don't understand what's
going on here eventually you will after
a couple of lessons and the last import
is a serviceworker which will let the
app load faster on subsequent visits in
production we won't be looking into it
as it's out of the scope of this course
but I will provide a link below and you
can read about it if you like so let's
talk about react Dom render method it
can take up to three arguments the first
one is the react element that we want to
render the second one is the Dom
container in which we want to render our
react element and the third one is an
optional argument you can provide a
callback function to it we won't be
doing that but there you can store
whatever logic you want and if you're
wondering where this root element lives
it's under the public folder index dot
HTML file I've already changed the title
to tv-series app you can do that if you
like
and here you can find the root element I
mean the development with the ID of root
so let's close index.html and let's try
to create our own react element and
render it to the Dom so I'll create a
variable with a name of quitting and
I'll assign create element to it and
also this method takes up three
arguments the first one is the tag that
we want to use I will be using an h1 tag
oops
the second argument is the props that
you want to provide to your element
don't worry if you don't know what props
mean you will find out in later lessons
but for now I'll only provide an empty
object and I will work just fine and the
third argument is the string that we
want to use inside our h1 tags and I'll
just say hello world take the greeting
variable pass it into the render method
save index loggias and now we're seeing
our newly created react element with
hello world greeting attached
inside ab dodge es we're seeing a
different kind of syntax this bit of
code also creates a react element but
it's using a syntax extension to
JavaScript which is called gsx as you
can probably tell this looks a lot
cleaner and readable
so let's refactor our newly created
react element to use gsx syntax wise is
really similar to plain JavaScript so
just open up h1 tags and type in hello
world save it and the result on our page
hasn't changed one bit under the hood
create react app is transpiling JSX
element to react elements with the help
of transpiler called Babel if you're
interested how the transpiling works I
will provide a link below and you can
read more about it if you like gsx also
fully supports JavaScript so you can
embed expressions inside of it let's
create a simple function which will just
return the current date inside of it
create a data object and let's just
return the current date
okay so we can refer to this function
inside our greeting variable GSX uses a
special kind of syntax which let the gsx
parser know that it needs to interpret
JavaScript expressions instead of a
string and let's just type in current
date and use this special syntax which
is just the curly braces and let's refer
to the function here save it and our
page is now rendering the current date
awesome also if you're interested this
is just known as an arrow function so
essentially it's identical to this kind
of syntax again the end result hasn't
changed at all through graduations on
using JSX the first time
we already have an example component
created for us by create react app let's
render it back inside index dodgy as
file we can delete the code that we've
written in the previous lessons we will
be using it anymore and let's refer to
the app component inside our render
method now if you're wondering why we're
using different kind of syntax which
looks more similar just to regular HTML
that's because we are rendering a fully
functional react component instead of
just a simple variable with some gsx
assigned to save index dot J's file go
back to your page check if everything is
working correctly and it is so let's
open up back the GS file and we can see
that we have a class created with the
name of app which is extending class
component provided for us by react and
inside this class we have just one
render method which is returning the JSX
that will render inside our page so
nothing too much difficult is happening
here and we can easily make the changes
to fit our needs
first of all let's delete the image and
we can also remove the import here save
it go back to our page and the image was
successfully removed but we have a big
gap under the title so open up app dot
CSS and find app header class and change
the height instead of 150 pixels change
it to 60 pixels
save it this looks much better okay
let's change our title to TV series list
and instead of this intro text we will
be creating our own first component so
let's create a variable with the name of
intro and assign the arrow function to
it which for now we'll just only return
this copied GSX here so be sure to add
one argument with the name of props
which is sure for properties and the
upcoming lesson you will understand what
that is and change the text to our first
functional component and referred here
see if AB dodgy yes and we have created
our first functional component so both
intro and app are identical from Reax
point of view although app has
additional features since it's extending
the component class provided by react we
will discuss those additional features
in the upcoming lessons functional
components are called functional because
there are literally just JavaScript
functions which return a react element
in our case we're just returning simple
GSX
it's really important to have your own
custom component capitalized since
that's the syntax convention that GSX
uses lowercase names will refer to
building components so it will be just
considered as simple HTML tags
and capitalized names will refer to your
custom components
now that we have written our own ya
component we can make AB GS a bit
cleaner and create a separate file for
the intro component under the SRC folder
create a folder with the name of
components inside the components folder
create a folder with the name of intro
and inside the intro folder create a
file with the name of index GS let's
copy our intro component from a blog yes
pass it back here and remember to import
react library since we're creating react
elements inside this file all that we
need to do is export the intro component
and we're good to go by the way if you
are wondering why we're using a sort of
different syntax here this is just known
as a shorthand syntax for arrow
functions so what goes after the
parenthesis is returned from this arrow
function and also one good thing to know
is that if you're passing only one
argument into your arrow function you
can delete the additional parentheses
here save it go back to AB dodges and
let's import intro from components intro
save Apogee yes and nothing has changed
on our page but what happens if we want
to use a different message inside intro
component ideally we want to reuse this
component but right now it will always
return just the same message
that's where properties get in think of
them just as function arguments to your
components
so inside index IGS we have one argument
passing in into the intro component and
here we can use those custom properties
with the help of the props object so
props is just a simple JavaScript object
with all of your custom properties
combined inside that Abdi yes let's
create a custom property to our intro
component with the name of message and
here we will add a string which will say
here you can find and find all of your
most loved series say vApp dodgy yes and
inside the intro component let's delete
this string and just access the message
property inside our props object save
and as you can see we are rendering our
intro component with custom property by
the way you can pass anything you'd like
so not only a string works you can pass
in a boolean a number array or even
functions
it's time to start adding additional
functionality to our app component
components that extend react component
class have additional features and one
of them is state what is state think of
it just as plain JavaScript object to
which your component reacts and renders
whatever is needed let's create our
state object and add a property to it
with the name of series and for now this
will only be just an empty alright we
can access the series array inside the
render function by simply getting it
from our state object just to be sure
that everything is working fine let's
print out the length of syriza right to
our page this state dot series length
save app dodges and the length of our
series array is rendering to the page
which is zero and that is correct so
just to keep our project a bit more
organized we already have components
folder created so let's add another
folder to it with the name of app and
move everything that is connected to the
app component to this folder so app dot
CSS AB dot G s and AB dot test IDs since
we moved it to a different folder we
need to change the directory for our app
component so just like that also we need
to change the name of our app component
since we already have a folder name for
it so just to make it easier I'll just
rename it to index GS that way we can
import it just like our intro component
and we don't need to specify the
additional JavaScript file
okay so everything is done inside our
app folder so what's left is just to
change the import inside index digest so
since we move this two components folder
let's add components save index yes and
we have the same page rendering once
again
we are class components have accessed
the so called lifecycle hooks Michigan
want your code when a particular
component mounts and mounts receive new
props and many other situations
let's take a look into a method called
component dead mount it'll be
immediately involved after the component
has been rendered what do we do inside
this method is completely up to us but
for now let's create an additional rate
with New York series which will hold
only two elements for now and the first
one will be nice a Vikings the second
one will be Game of Thrones let's use a
set timeout function which will take two
arguments the first one is just a
function and the second one is the light
after which your function will be
invoked inside the function let's use
sets state method which will take an
object as its first argument so what
sets state does it tells react that this
component and its children need to be
rendered with the updated state so let's
take the series property of our state
object and assign to it our newly
created series right save index IGS go
back to your page and the length of the
series changed after two seconds let's
go back to index the GS and I want to
show you a trick so inside your object
if you're using the same names of your
property you can actually delete this
bit of code and this will just take the
series property and assign our newly
created series array to it so save index
da GS go back to your page refresh it
and the link of the series should be two
after two seconds
you
in order to send a request to the server
first of all when you install a library
which will let us do it there were a lot
of options out there what I personally
love to use fesh we can install fetch
with no package manager I'll just copy
this bit of code and pass it into the
common line press ENTER ok after
installing fetch let's open up our app
again by typing in NPM start ok so we
have our app running back again so let's
go to the code editor and open up index
dot J's file inside our app component
and let's import fetch let's just sign
up the request to the API whenever our
app component renders obviously we want
to do that inside component Adnan method
let's get rid of this bit of code and
type in fetch which will take a URL as
its first argument we will be using a
service call to be Mae's API which will
let us obtain different kind of
information for various TV series while
here I'm just searching for TV series
with the name of Vikings and fetch
returns a promise so obviously we need
to resolve it and in order to do that
we'll need to chain in that method which
takes up a function as its first
argument and inside this function we
will have access to the response object
so for now let's just console.log the
response object and go back to our page
open the console and here we can see
that we're getting back the response
object what we need to do right now is
parse the result and get the JSON from
this object it's really easy to do so
what we need to type in this response
JSON
and this will just return the JSON from
the response object obviously so what's
great about promises is that we can
chain that methods and what we are
returning from this line will get back
here so we'll get back the JSON and
let's for me now also just console login
okay save it and we're getting back ten
items and let's take a look into few of
them so the show ID the URL and the name
of the series and we have a lot more
going on inside the show object so what
we can do inside this method is that we
can actually set the state of our app so
let's use this sad state and let's add
in our series to the series property of
our state saving the XDS go back to the
page and we're getting back the length
of series all right then okay that's
exactly what we wanted and just to be
sure let's refresh it one more time
and yes we're getting back the response
from the API
right now we launch an API request every
time our app component renders but if
you think about it this is the app
component really need to know about the
TV series array or one on how the call
will be launched the answer is
definitely not we want to keep our app
as modular and as simple as possible
that means creating separate components
when it's logical to do so in react
there is a common pattern use known as
presentational components and container
components the idea is very simple
inside your presentational components
you will be concentrating on how things
look
you wouldn't specify how the data is
loaded or manipulated and inside
containers you would have all of your
functionality that means how things
would work how data is fetched and
manipulated most of the time containers
will be stateful that means they will
use state to serve data to our
presentational components okay so let's
create a containers folder under the SRC
folder inside the containers folder
let's also add another folder with the
name of series and inside the series
folder let's add an index ES File import
react component from react create a
class with the name of series which
extends component let's render for now
only add F let's type in series
container export default series okay
inside our app component let's import
series from dinner series and let's
render it under our the length of a
write message
save indexes go back to the page and
we're rendering the series container
okay so what we need to do right now is
we actually need to copy this code and
let's space it into the series component
and we also need to get this message
let's also paste it inside our div here
let's save the series file then the
component file and let's go back to our
page once again and nothing has changed
so we're seeing exactly the same result
as we had at the start of the lesson but
now we have divided the logic between
separate components in the next lesson
we will introduce a serious list
presentational component which will list
our series inside an unordered list
now that we have our series we return
from the API call it's time for us to
create the series list component which
will run through the TV series so other
the components folder create a series
list folder inside that folder let's add
index.js file import import react from
react for now let's just create a
functional component which will return
just the dev side that they have let's
type in series list component let's
expects port default it and that way we
can import it inside our series
container ok now that we have that let's
render it under the message of our
series story length and I'll add in the
list property to the component we'll get
this list properly inside our props so
I'll just pass in this state series here
save index dodge yes go back to the page
see if everything is rendering
accordingly and it is so let's go back
to the series list component and we can
delete this message
let's add an unordered list inside that
list now that we have our less property
let's type and props list and we'll use
a map function inside that function
let's get the series and less
return a list item and inside that left
side and what we want to do is show the
name of our series to save that go back
to your page and we're getting every
single show name from our series all
right good so we want of course to look
a little bit better we don't want these
dots around flowing it out here so what
we can do is add class name and let's
type in series list inside the series
list folder we can create a index that
CSS file and let's type in series list
and less style type none now that we
have that we of course also need to
import it here so import index dot CSS
save that we're not seeing the dots
floating around on the left side also I
don't like the padding on the left so
I'll just remove that as well now this
looks centered awesome
one thing that's left you talk about yes
we're actually getting this warning from
yak so it says that each child in the
way or iterator should have a unique key
prop so what we need to do is on our
list item we need to add a property with
the name of key and let's type and
series shell ID just to make it a little
bit cleaner okay save that
open up the console and we're not seeing
the warning anymore so what we did is we
add a key to our last item so keys help
react identify which items have changed
or have been added or removed so the
best way to pick a key is to use a
string that uniquely identifies a list
item a monic siblings most often you
will have an ID for that to use your
data as key but when you don't have a
stable ID for your render items you may
want to use an index as a key just as
the last resort just know that it's not
recommended and you should always try to
use an ID that's unique for your list
item
it is possible to create additional
components inside a component which will
not be available outside of it this
makes your code a little bit more
readable and little bit more semantic
and it's just a good practice to use so
let's create a new variable with the
name of series last item will of course
pass props to it and let's return
whatever we have inside our series list
unordered list item and right here we
can return series list item
let's pass series to it by the way we
can also destructor eyes our props
variable inside our series list item so
we can just open up parentheses and type
in series this will just take all of the
properties whichever you want from your
props object so I'll save index GS go
back to our page and let's really
nothing has changed so for now it may
seem redundant that we're creating just
a new component for a list item but
later on in upcoming lessons we will be
adding a little bit more information to
it and then it'll be just a lot cleaner
and simpler to understand
in a previous lesson we were the
factoring series last component what
they forgot to do is add the key
property to the newly created component
let's go back to our code editor and
copy the key property from the list item
and paste it into the series list item
component 7th access and the error is
gone
let's open up containers series index GS
and right now we're only fetching series
with the name of Vikings but of course
we want to make this process a little
bit more dynamic under the length of
series or a message I'll open up a div
and inside of it I'll create an input
with the type of text and I'll also
assign an unchanged handler to it so
what this handler does is that whenever
our input value changes it will fire an
event to whatever method we assign to it
I'll create a method inside the
component with the name of on series
input change we will be getting an event
object from the unchanged handler and
I'll cancel that log the event object
and I'll also cancel a log the value of
our input let's take our series input
change and assign it to our input save
index as yes and let's type in something
so I'll type in game of thrones and I'm
getting the value of our input and I'm
also getting the event object what we
can do with that is we can actually copy
the code from component in mouth and
let's face it end here they all series
input change essentially what we want to
do is make this part dynamic we can do
that with the help of string
interpolation
inside JavaScript it's used with a very
interesting symbol called grave accent
it looks like this and I agree the
naming is a little bit weird we need to
wrap our URL inside these symbols and
let's stake out the Vikings the
hard-coded serious name and what you
want to do later is type in a dollar
sign open up curly braces and let's copy
the value of our input and paste it to
the fat URL save index that yes we're
not getting anything from our series
away and that is because we move the
component amount method so if I type
anything into the input let's say I'll
type in the same Vikings we're getting
the same length of our array and we're
getting the series dynamically
it's time to add some conditional
rendering to the page we only want a
lawyer spinning up under the input
whenever I type in something and we also
want a friendly message which will say
that no TV series have been found if the
API does not give back any results with
the given value of the input
let's open up series container and you
need to add few more properties to the
state the first one will be series name
I'll just assign an empty string to it
and it will just help keep track of
whatever we have inside the input
because currently we're not doing that
and I'll also and it's fetching property
and I'll set it to false and this will
help us know whenever we're fetching
something from the API let's get all of
these properties inside the render
method
I'll just get those from this state and
the first thing that I want to do is I
want to set the value of our input to
the series name so right now it will
only be an empty string I'll also make
it look a bit better
let's save in the X yes go back to the
page and now whenever I type something
into the input it will show the results
but it shouldn't show anything inside
the input and that is because I'm not
actually setting the value and we need
to do that inside the on series input
change method let's step in this set
state and I'll set the state of series
name to the target value and I'll also
make the fetching true and of course
after the actual fetching is done let's
set is fetching
- Falls now that we have all of our
state management done we can actually go
to the page and check if everything is
working fine and let's go back to the
render method and we can now actually at
the conditional rendering to the render
method
first of all let's remove the length of
syriza right message we don't need that
anymore
and just under the second if open up
curly braces and here I want to check if
the series length is zero then we will
know that no series have been returned
from the API and if the series name
string of also trim it is equal to an
empty string now we know that nothing
has been typed in and the series all
right is equal to zero so we don't have
anything to show to the user so then we
can type please enter
series name into the input and let's
open the second curly braces and
whenever the series length is also equal
to zero but we actually typed something
in into the input then we know that
nothing has been fetched from the API
and we can tell that no TV series have
been found with this name
let's save index that yes go back to the
page now let's double check to see if
everything is working correctly so we're
seeing the message right now and if I
type something into it the message is
gone and
stipe some gibberish and we're getting
that no TV series have been found with
this name good okay
so last thing that I want to do is I
want to check whether we're fetching
something from the API so let's open up
the curly braces again and I'll type in
if it's fetching it's true
then for now let's just show loading
message and if fetching is false I'll
just show the series list again save and
exit yes go back to the page and we
should get the loading message whenever
we type something into it
and yeah we're actually getting it it's
just fairly hard to see because the
response from the API is fairly quick
in the previous lesson we left a little
bug whenever I type something into you
the input even though I'm still waiting
for response from the API I'm already
getting the message that no TV series
have been found and that is because we
didn't specify that we actually
shouldn't be fetching whenever we want
to show this message and the same goes
for the message above save index IGS and
we're not getting that mob anymore the
last thing that I want to show you is
how to add an image with react so I'll
create a folder with the name of loader
inside of it I'll just add index GS
important react create the loader
component export it and I already have a
loader gift inside my assets folder you
can use whatever loader icon you'd like
it doesn't really matter so what you
need to do is you need to get the source
of the loader and I'll just name it
loader SRC from assets lower gif
so essentially you are just importing
the source and what I want to do here is
create an image and I'll add in the SRC
like this and we also want to provide an
alternative property because react will
give up warnings if you don't do that
I'll just type in loader icon save your
newly created
go back to the serious container let's
import it from loader whenever we're
loading we're not showing that old
message anymore we want to show the
loader component saving the excess go
back to the page and we're actually
seeing the loader popping up inside our
page I also want to do it make it a
little bit smaller because right now
it's really big and I want to show you
how you might want to do that on an
element level maybe you don't want to
create a new style sheet for that yeah
it gives you an ability to add styles to
an element and you want to provide an
object to it I'll say a width will be 75
pixels and I'll save the lower component
go back to my page and the loader icon
is looking a lot better
we a crowd or is the sound of growling
library for react I've opened up the NPM
page for react router and here we have a
short explanation how we need to install
this library into our app so it's saying
that if we're writing an application
that will run in the browser you should
install instead we are our Dom so let's
do that
open up your comment line and let's type
in NPM install course we want to save it
react rather down now that we have a
crowd or Dom installed on our
application open up indexes IDs and
import browser rather from react
valeriy DOM and we need to wrap around
our app component inside this component
and this will keep track of your UI in
sync with the URL save index - yes and
let's open our containers series index
and what I want to do next is copy the
entry code I'll just the latest from our
app component and paste it into the
series component just above the endpoint
of course don't forget to import intro
from intro save series container close
it and we don't need the intro anymore
here as well see that we're seeing the
same result but we just made our app
component a little bit cleaner and move
the info component into the series
container okay the next step is to
create an additional component we'll
call it main and here we'll have all of
our routes so I need to import react
from react I also need to import the
switch component and also the route
component from react rather down then
I'll create the main component passive
props and I'll return the switch and
inside that switch for now I'll have
only one route exact path
and the component will be series let's
export main component and of course they
also need to import the series container
from wow series container ok save index
legend yes and inside our app component
let's delete the series container so we
won't be actually rendering it inside
the app component but it will render the
main component from main okay and I'll
copy and paste it here save the app
component go back to the page and
nothing has changed but right now we're
actually using reactor algorithm to
render our series container and in the
next lesson we'll add an additional page
and then you'll see how we can render
different pages with yeah crowd rhythm
once show multiple pages on our
application but right now we only have
one container so I need to create
another one I'll call it single series
this container will shell a series with
a little bit more information that what
we have on our series container and for
that I'll need react and this will be a
class components I'll need component
class single series and extends
component render turn death and I'll
just type in single series inside the
paragraph and export defaulted great go
back to you the main component and
import single series from containers
single series and we want to add an
additional route the path will be series
and an ID this idea will represent the
idea of the series that we want to show
and of course it will be dynamic we will
be getting it from the series container
and I also need to add in the component
to the route and there will be single
series save index that yes let's try and
go to our newly created container so I
need to write series so let's say one
two three
we're getting back the single series
message that we just created it would be
nice of course to get this ID and we can
try and look inside the props see that
open up the console and what I'm looking
for is the match property and inside the
match property we have another object
and this fell params and here we have
the ID
that we want to show so I can actually
just type in the show ID will be this
props and if I recall correctly match
params ID match Rams ID save that we
don't need this anymore and we're
getting back the ID from our URL
whenever I type something in into you
our input getting back the results that
I want but I want the results to be
linkable and I just show up as a simple
shrink and for that we need to open up
series last component we need to import
link from react rather Dom and we need
to add the link into the series list
item and as the name implies this
component that works just as a simple
link and I want to link it to series
series show ID I'm just making the link
dynamic and it will always show the
correct ID and link to the correct show
with the idea Tash of the show so save
that go back to the page and I'll type
in same series Vikings and click on that
and I'm getting the single serious
result with the ID that I want with the
help of that ID I can go back to the
single series container and we will be
fetching the series from the API with
the ID and since we will be fetching
something I want to have the loader and
I want to create state for the single
series add one property to it it will be
show and I want to fetch the show from
the API I'll just copy the fetch from
single or sorry from the series
container and I want to fetch it to
different URL of course because I will
be getting only a single TV show and
this is the dynamic part so this is the
ID that I want to use from
route I can get it back from the props
I'll create an additional variable ID
and all the structure eyes the match
params
object get the ID back and paste it into
the URL of course I also want to change
the sad state method because I don't
have series or fetching properties
anymore I want to have it set state to
show to be JSON and now whatever our
component mounts we will be getting back
the shell to our container so the first
thing I want to do inside the render
method I want to get the shell from the
state and whenever the show is equal to
null I want to be showing the loader and
whenever the show is not null for now
I'll just show a message that show has
been loaded add it into paragraph tags
and I'll also constantly log the show
for now just to see what it has
it says that the show has been loaded
and I'm actually getting back the object
from the API I'll reload it one more
time so they can see the lawyer popping
up
yeah it's they're just not showing for a
more lengthy amount of time okay so now
that we have the show object we can
start and showing the information that
we want into the page so I will be
showing the show name then I also want
to show the premiere and that will be
inside shell premièred then I want to
show the rating I'll be showing the
rating average then episodes and that is
a little bit more difficult one it's
living inside the embedded property so
hard to copy show embedded episodes
lengths so I'm just showing the length
of their right and that will be the
count of the episodes and lastly I want
to show the image alternative will be
show and the source for that will be
show image and I think that I want to
get the medium sized one medium save
that go back to the page and we're
getting back the info that we want and
just to be sure that it works okay
let's go back to the main page and type
in Game of Thrones which is also an
awesome series
so click that and we're getting back the
results that we want we can close the
console and if we are thinking that you
can create an additional component for
this HTML you're probably right but I
won't be doing that and I encourage you
to try it yourself this is the last
lesson and I hope that you really like
the series and I'm waiting for your
feedback and please tell me if something
was wrong and if you love the series
just leave a good rating thanks and good
luck
working with react